大家呢 我也是小三零
今天分享明感节应该如何
正确的温和有效
现装节面
我在想说发现有很多的明感节的宝宝
都不会洗脸
这应该是大部分的明感节的宝宝
皮膚品上恢复的慢的一个体调的原因
我们皮膚品上身上的心肚没有
我们去过饭它的这个速度快
平均高温同时一年到时间
直到我遇到了一个医生
它交动一个非常温和的洗脸的方式
我长达一年多的高温红竟然在一两个月
就会发好了
而且一直到现在我的皮膚品上都很好
但今天针对如何洗脸
把我知道的支持都分享给你们
那先双明感节应该如何正确的现装
在现装产品的选举
放上我建议明感节的宝宝选择
要一样伏效果的
现装容或者是现装高
那我用的是这两个我之前不能分享
我的非常温和的现装高和现装有
我今天分享这个现装有的
反正洗干净以后
干手干练
按下五斤我一半时会用五斤
用量大一点呢
受话都会更高
对皮膚的伤害就会減少很多
那我的皮膚一生建议我要一种
按啥的方式去的现装
那我之前也有分享
我这种现装方法
有很多把我担心中就按压的现装手
把后面写不干净的
那你像我的毛孔是一个动
如果你是一种模擦的方式去现装
你就是一直在打模我们这个皮膚的表皮
所以一直而走之你会感觉皮膚
终于越来越薄越来越明感
而这个动能你在表皮一时打模
你清潔不到它的里面
但是如果你是一种按下的方式
去现装我们的手就变成一个鞋盘
这样就可以有效地把这个毛孔里的材装给带一吹
我就这样一直按样
多按几次
那远家比较薄的地方的是一定要这样按样
但是在我们的T君
脚这次比较厚的胸的
我可以稍微地打圈给他带过
那这样现装呢
我们在配合一个非常温和养夫的鞋装产品
就不会伤害我们的皮膚
更有利于我们的皮膚品上恢复
那在养主块我们就先把手上的这些
装有鞋盘车
这样
鞋盘车后我们就这时
想知道这个水呢就在脸上
变成这样按穿
让鞋装有和水充分的尖丑
让这些鞋装有给它有化起来
那现在把手里的鞋
带进行第二次有鞋盘
其实我自己切的话
就非常快速
就逼人眼睛的几次用
但我要误际成强度的强细一点
那第三次
点周可以上来打鞋盘
现在我们的脸车尖盘
又已经有它什么
白打的样子
周可以用大量的鞋盘
还给洗干净
一个好的鞋装车盘
你现在装车后是完全不需要儿子清潔的
那鞋碗脸之后
用这种一副性的连融轻
把脸上使得按掉
不要去拨擦脸
按掉就可以了
好了
我们一个非常温高的
用两封的一个鞋装就完成了
你看我的量
一点的螃蟹螃蟹
不能再上好
那我现在来跟我们的示範
从两个温度的用鞋盘
我之前的视频
又被你们分享过
我建议明看见的宝宝
选择有ABG
或者是甜菜箭
这两个车封得鞋的奶
会有比较的鞋和暗鸡酸的鞋奶
跟温和鞋只不熟了
那下APG是奶
就是有一个问题
就是它虽然很温泼的
它的鞋盘不好
它鞋盘就有点像一个皮脂一样
然后泡培很少
那我前段时间在想
出上来了这个APG鞋奶
是我批眼的朋友
推荐给我的
它说它用自己的鞋盘
很舒服的鞋盘很好
我发现它这个鞋盘
确实不一样
我说爸爸的鞋盘
它是这种理念状态
对一点水量手的衣服
就可以突出很多号码
没有两个乘的最敏感最非常的油烤
那我们的鞋盘奶
鞋盘也要参考
暗鸢式的鞋盘
鞋鞋鞋贴区合
下巴走走
也不只尊敌
广身的地方
可以多给了暗鸡的鞋
可以稍微地拿一项圈
但主要是你暗鸢回复的鞋
那脸脚呢
就是这样稍微的
带过
就是什么
好
我们现在就可以用大量的碎把这个泡培充走就可以
那也是想要让它用这种棉肉精
把水放暗疆就可以了
不关于敏感几乎和权
和节奋证品如何系列
我都说完了
如果我们还是你问可以乃
给我留言评论
上个下期再见
拜拜